did you take another photo yet I'd like
to okay what the
heck
what you had to face it that's what
reminded him Jesus
man oh okay I got it got a couple can I
see yeah it's really pretty yeah what's
that side why is it dark it's the
lighting yeah yeah better lighting I
don't like it don't I I don't like my
but it looks like a Afghanistan cave
I've seen a lot I've seen a lot of male
butth holes can I have a look genuinely
no no no it's beautiful I've seen a lot
I've a lot of but angel on my butthole I
swear you I won't I won't do it without
consent what if we did it with this
light so that then it's you've got
better light so you don't have a dark
shadow on one but I I don't think it's
the light I think I think the other side
is it's discoloration that's no no wrong
she's correct it's the lighting it's
Harvey Dent there it is it's it's two
faced but two [__] two assle you want
like do you want to use like the light
on my phone as well can I get like a can
I get like a uh filter oh sepia or
something we're going to light your
[__] before I
take I feel bad for the people in the
corner having to make eye contact with
you
around okay tell me when I can turn back
this is he's going deep right now I love
that this is our programming right
now so uh yeah Bobby for the audience is
just bending over per usual uh good
they're taking photos his butthole good
I'm good
okay that's sweat oh that's sweat that's
sweat all you know what I got to shave I
think no just okay that's okay consent
no that erase that one okay I'll if you
do if you do Too Faced I'll never talk
to you
again honestly really impressive do the
one I just did not the other one okay
sorry so you I have consent to look yeah
okay let me see oh my God your said go
that one go look at her face look at her
face oh wow wow look at her eyes she
look at her eyes look at her eyes that's
is she pretending or what beautiful
right she zoomed in so I she zoomed in
so why did you zoom in don't zoom in she
zoomed in so cool don't give me the
phone don't zoom in man she keep zooming
in zooming in what are you looking for
in
there Jimmy haa you
have you barely have spokes like you're
so smooth you're so smooth thank you
that's a good thing so smooth so clean
yeah wow and like even like going under
like the taint and the ball is like it's
really smooth barely any hair thank you
thank you thank you barely any like
coloration difference like yeah wow
that's good news for everyone very tight
looking really tight very tight looking
have you seen it yeah I've seen it 50
million times and she keeps zooming up
on it dude it's like no I keep zooming
cuz I'm like yeah stop zooming I've
never seen it that I keep zooming
because it's like what are you looking
for in there man the actual hole cuz
it's so tight I'm like where I don't
think you have a hole man I might not
have a hole it looks like it's sewn
together it looks Human Centipede like
it's close like doesn't it like when
it's this zo Jesus let me let me see let
me see let me see how Zoom no it's like
let me see look it honestly looks like a
fissure but show him show him how
zo I don't want to ever see that's out
of control that's out of control that's
out of control man wait where is your
hole that's why I zooming I kept zooming
to find the hole yeah yeah yeah don't
ever Zoom like that again that was rude
dude that's wild that's wild wild I
couldn't Zoom yeah yeah that's wild wa
you're so right yeah it's so tight that
it's like I was like where's let me take
a photo of your the entry it's frog
tight oh it is yeah all right that's
good then that's good the damn up W good
job the welome wait why were we looking
at that in the first I have no idea oh I
have no idea I think we were trying to
count the ring the spokes the spok no SP
no spoke yeah you're you don't have um
ridges you're very because people see
that I um that I look young for my age
maybe I have a very young butthole as
well yeah you never had boats or
anything not in the butle